Vìng Pastor thành phố Xí Minh cho biết, qua giám sát sĩ tế cho thấy sịch sốt sốt vết đang tích tục dễn biến
phúc tạm với 20,5 cà mắc và 1 cà từ vòng trong 20 mốt tình đậu 50,5 cà.
Tăng sống mít tư, phần chăm só với cùng khi 50,5 cà mấy tư.
Chúng mình mỗi tình tại khu vực phía 50,5 cà mắc.
Tuy nhiên, số cà từ vòng vẫn ấm ấm ấm ấm nhất trong vòng 50,5 cở lại đây.
Bình tay chân biển cũng khi nhận mùi tám nghiền chính trong chim bê bà cà mắc,
tăng mấy chiến phần chăm só với 50,5 cà mấy tư, kinh nhân chưa có chương vợp tử vòng.
Hịt, số cà mắc nghĩ nhận có xù hướng chính lại.
Tư tình mỗi đến tình 25,5 cà mấy lắm,
toàn cu vực phía năm đặc biến tổng cộng 30,5 cà mắc sởi, trong đậu có xấu chương vợp tử vòng.
Sau với cùng khi 50,5 cà mấy tư, số cà mắc sởi tăng vỏ vối mức chính lệp lên tới 30,5 cà mấy tám cà.
Chứ dễn biến phúc tạm của tình hình dịch bệnh chuyến trong vòng ngoài nước,
bộ ít tế yêu cầu các sự ý tế để mạnh công tác chuyển thông phòng trong dịch,
đặc biệt tại vùng sau, vùng xa, vùng đồng bảo sinh tộc thiêu số.
Bộ cũng đề nghĩ các địa phương cần tăng cửa giám sát,
cập nhật số liệu dịch tế theo quy định,
phát hiện sớm các ủ dịch, các số hiệu bất thường nhằm ký thời khói vùng,
sự lý chực để hạn chế lệ lần.
Các có sự khám chữa bệnh phải sánh sàng thu dung,
điều chỉ bệnh nhân không để sẻ ra tình chẳng quá tại hoặc bệnh nhân không được cấp dữ,
điều chỉ ký thời.